ну і кого ви по набирали нам в parla
дорогі виборці партії слуга народу
якщо у депутата
немає власного житла у Києві
держави згідно із законами може йому
компенсувати є він звернеться за
матеріальна допомога держави може
йому компенсувати витрати на оренду житла
це сьогодні в районі 20 20 з хвостиком
тисяч гривень 20 тисяч гривень на місяць
депутати які не мають власного
житла винаймають квартири отримують
компенсації від держави сьогодні
оприлюднили свої декларації, якщо у них
гроші і якщо у них совість депутати
портьє слуга народу олександр Трухін
задекларував 21 із 7 мільйона
артем кунаю в дев'ять і дев'ять мільйонів
степан чернявський 96 це я вам зараз
диктує список усіх тих депутатів
які отримують компенсацію за наші
вами гроші компенсацію за житло у Києві
Павло Якименко 9 і 4 мільйони це все
депутати партії слуга народів пости та
хлопці з народу євгеній при турняку 7
мільйонів олексій кузнеців 6 і 9 федор
вінні славський 6-8 богдан тарахті
6 4 андрей костин 48 Олександр Олексій
чук 43
геннадій касою 41 олександр воропаєв 2
та 9
вона личман 2,6 мільйона задекларувала
артем чорномору в два з половиною
мільйона максим зурі в 2 мільйони едуард
пробачу
1 та 9 мільйона дмитрій нальотів 16 олена
ковальчук мільйон двісті це дані з
їх декларації які не падають і відразу
не кажуть держави у мене немає грошей
допоможи мені будь ласка компенсують
вартість житла оренди житла це ми ще
не говоримо про вислали стефанчика
який знімав відома історія
який знімав орендував житло про свою
власної тещі отримав компенсацію від
держави хлопці максимум ужанський
отримує компенсацію за житло максим
бужу
поглянь у декларації 300 32 тисячі
доларів він дав комусь у борг та вечері
218 тисяч доларів просто у тумбочці
лежать на дрібні витрати відповідно до і
ваш декларації і він отримує компенсацію
за житло за березень наших з вами грошей з
бюджету з наших податків за березень
виплачено 2 мільйони 300 тисяч на
компенсацію житла депутатам це наші
вами гроші 2 мільйони 300 тисяч рік
цих грошей у них порахуйте скільки
так ось я хочу вам поставити просте запитання
депутати якщо у вас
совість
мені здається що совісті немає
а якщо у вас розум зараз я звертаюсь до
всім тим хто голосував за цих депутатів
якщо у вас разу або так само як з
совістю депутатів і запитайте леви з
кожного
з кожного з цього списку з цих
депутатів
якщо у них совість і для чого їм
компенсація у 20 тисяч гривень за житло
з не плануєш 21 мільйон доходу для
чого
де совість і взявши розум напишіть у
коментарях
[музика]